الاوضاع على الحدود الباكستانيه الافغانيه
تشتعل من جديد في معبر طرحم الحدودي ووفقا
لاعلام الافغاني وقع اشتباك بين قوات
الطالبان وحرس الحدود الباكستانيه بدات
قوات طالبان اطلاق النار على الجانب
الباكستاني ما ادى لاصابه جندي باكستاني
بالمقابل رد حرس الحدود الباكستاني باطلاق
النار الامر الذي ادى الى مقتل لمواطن
افراني قبل ذلك وتحديدا في ولايه نان
جرهار شرقيه افغانستان ذكرت صحف افغانيه
ان القوات الجويه الباكستانيه شنت غارات
جويه على معاقل حركه طالبا باكستان داخل
الاراضي الافغانيه على الحدود مع باكستان
وذلك بعد ثلاثه ايام من اعلاني مجلس الامن
القومي الباكستاني تنفيذ غرارات العسكريه
على معاقل الحركه داخل افغانستان طالبا
باكستان وبحسب وسائل الاعلام من باكستانيه
ردت على هذه الهجمات حيث اكد المتحدث باسم
الحركه استهداف كمين للشرطه مع اسفر عن
مقتل ثمانيه من رجال الامن شهر ديسمبر
الماضي ااا هذا الشهر كان الاكثر دمويه
اذا في هجمات طالبان باكستان على الحكومه
ويلعام ستشتد المواجهه اكثر وسط من طالبان
الافغانيه